good morning John this morning I woke up
used some water then I used some more
water than I used some water and used
some more water again if you walk around
my house and jostle enough silver things
there's a really good chance that clean
safe delicious cold or hot water will
start leaking out of somewhere this is a
nickel if I see a nickel on the sidewalk
there's a fairly good chance that I
won't even stop to pick it up all the
water that I used this morning cost me
about one nickel March 22nd is World
Water Day John I think that we should
take a moment to think about how
freaking awesome our lives are last week
I woke up in Miami I got on a plane
landed in port-au-prince and then I got
on another much smaller much bumpier
much scarier plane and then landed in a
place called pinyon a small town of
20,000 people in central Haiti I went to
pinyon with water.org
to meet the people who live there and
find out how those people live their
lives the morning after arriving in
Haiti I rode in the back of a truck to
Sivan taboc a village of around 60
households the people of Sivan taboc got
one of water dogs carefully selected
local partners involved by sending a
letter to the mayor of pinyon explaining
their situation these people are the
well committee they're the people who in
a perfect world wrote the letter
together expressing an interest to have
some organization come in and help them
build a well two of these guys glue and
I'll here and boats on the other end
clearly were the guys who actually wrote
the letter the rest of the people were
wrangled by water orgs requirement to
have a broader coalition be formed this
coalition is necessary because otherwise
boats and Gulino could just say that
they are the ones who brought the well
to the community and that everyone owes
them a gigantic ative gratitude and in
the worst case scenario they could
actually start selling water for their
own personal profit these guys actually
seemed a little bit frustrated with the
process they seem to think that water
torque should just come and drill the
well and leave them alone and not change
the way any of this stuff is working but
since water.org requires this committee
to be formed a committee with people
from different genders different
religions different neighborhoods
different families the well becomes an
asset of the community not of one church
not of one family this woman ola
obviously has seen a lot and wasn't
taking no blip from no one I wouldn't
want her as a second grade teacher but
I'd be happy having her represent me in
local government if I heed the old guy
at the end here he was cracking jokes
the whole time trying to make everybody
feel more at ease and he was obviously a
very well-respected member of the
community gen Baptiste them in the
middle who I didn't catch while she was
standing out was a quiet woman but she
was obviously there for her kids she was
very frustrated by the
fact that her kids had been sick and
that they spent more time fetching water
than they did at school Jenna this girl
in the awesome hat the youngest member
of the well committee was probably the
most frustrated of everyone she knew
that there had to be a better way but
she wasn't interested at all in begging
she was just fed up with the situation
and hadn't yet reached an age where she
thought that it was intractable she
thought that there was a solution and
she was really ready for that solution
she seemed really able to step outside
of the situation and be able to critique
it in a way that was humorous not overly
critical I just said that she could
critique it without being critical that
is how awesome she was these are the
people with the savant to Bach well
committee and this is mostly what I
wanted to do today I just wanted to
introduce you to them and now what I
want you to do is go to my daughter org
slash vlogbrothers and you can follow
this community as they meet their
milestones water.org has a very specific
outline of what needs to happen for a
community come together and create a
sustainable water project not just
something that will help them for the
next six months but something that will
really redefine their community I
learned a lot of things in Haiti and one
of the most important was that not all
nonprofit organizations are created
equal and now myself having done the due
diligence and seeing the way that water
org operates I'm very comfortable asking
you to donate money to water or the
people of Sivan taboc have a lot of hard
work to do before they can have a
sustainable source of water in their
community we can do our part as well
following them on that journey and
helping them through that journey
there's no amount that is too great or
small we're just helping people get out
of a situation that sucks
thanks to water oregon haiti outraged
all the amazing people who were able to
help me bring this story onto the
youtubes sized screen whatever size
screen this is and if you want to check
out more videos from haiti lisanova and
timothy delaghetto where they're with me
you should check out their channels they
just made videos about Haiti as well
John I'll see you on Wednesday
you